[Applause]
happy Thursday everybody all
right oh thank you it's a girl scouts
over there we'll get to brain dead Biden
in a
minute if I remember but first remember
last year when Sports site dead spin
posted a pick of a Kansas City Chief's
fan showing only half his face the face
painted black implying he's in blackface
and thus a horrible racist in reality
his other cheek was painted red those
were his team colors but dead spin
didn't show you that here's a
flashback instead of getting the
approval that most woke media Caren
generally batkin the scumbag Rider had
to face the new community notes function
of Elon musk's X in record time
Community notes showed the kids full
photo not just the half painted black
and now thanks to a madeup charge of
blackace the folks at dead spin are
guilty of egg
face
and I keep getting
younger so dead spin tried to backtrack
adding a half-ass apology quote
unfortunately the article Drew attention
to the fan though our intended Focus was
on the NFL and its checkered history on
race it was all about the
fan he had painted team colors on his
face but then you painted a Target on
his life but now that 9-year-old boy's f
family is suing dead spin for
maliciously and wantedly attacking the
child alleging dead spin's RAC drenched
political agenda and the story is even
more hilarious and that the kid is also
a member of the Chumash tribe join the
club said one
Senator
but easy waiting for that but it doesn't
look good for dead spin the writer Karen
J Phillips and the company go media
which owns dead spin my only hope hope
is that little Chiefs fan gets enough
money to buy dead Spin and turn it into
a pickle ball
quart if it's possible fact is racial
smears now have consequences you can't
put out a RAC drenched political agenda
and expect that the victims won't
inevitably fight back but where did this
kind of punitive ideology come from well
you can blame the race hustling industry
and among its leaders is a very white
woman named Robin D'Angelo Robins claim
to fame is her book White fragility in
2018 she describes it as this quote it's
a state in which even a minimal
challenge to the white position becomes
intolerable triggering a range of
defensive moves including argumentation
invalidation silence withdrawal and
claims of being attacked and
misunderstood meaning if you're white
and I call you racist and you disagree
you're fragile which makes you even more
racist so it's a total lose lose
situation like choosing between Jesse
wat Prime Time and Jesse wat
anytime yeah all for that joke and in
one training session she said this to be
less white is to be less oppressive less
arrogant less certain less defensive
less ignorant more humble but by that
criteria she must be the whitest white
person to ever white in the Earth why
does a white woman think black people
need her help anyway isn't that arrogant
and the opposite of humble I thought
this broad was against white saviors
unless of course it's her and she's
making a buck but isn't it weird how
anti-racism always ends up being extra
racist it's a solution that makes things
worse you know like a vaccine that makes
your heart fall
out but say what you want about her lazy
stupid worldview she has a strong
financial incentive to to keep up with
this divisive crap in 2021 she was
making more than 700 Grand a year from
speaking gigs Book Sales corporate
diversity Consulting and getting 14
Grand per lecture well I hope she's
donating all that to reparations or at
least buying Joy read a new
wig so what's Robin up to now well here
she is explaining the single image that
captures the concept of white
supremacy the single image I use to
capture the concept of white supremacy
is is um Michelangelo cistin Chaple God
creating man you know where where God is
in a cloud and there's all these angels
and he's reaching out and he's
touching I don't know who that is David
or
something and God is white and David's
White and the angels are white like that
that is the perfect convergence of white
supremacy
patriarchy she's like a robot she
confused David and Adam just CU they're
both white I guess we all we all look
alike you all look alike yes so damn
confused need name TS around here yeah
first of all the painting is called the
creation of Adam the title might hold a
clue as to the identity of the person
being created and if you think about it
God doesn't have a race you idiot he's
definitely a man though cuz on the
seventh day he rested a woman would go
shopping a sexist would say
yeah of course D'Angelo will say she
shouldn't need to know anything about
history or art because it's just white
supremacy and how convenient that is for
her she can churn out untethered idiocy
without doing any real work whatsoever
but thankfully those brilliant works of
art will be remembered long after
Robin's gone that is if we don't all die
in the Civil War she's pushing but what
other works of art can we deem bigoted
sexist racist or transphobic I mean look
closely at the famous painting The Last
Supper not a black person in sight and
what about rhoden's the Thinker he's
obviously thinking about ways he can
keep the black man
down or Edward munches the scream he's
clearly upset because he saw Tyrus using
his condo's
pool cuz if you can find racism in the
cinee chapel you can find it anywhere
and that's the grift of people like
Robin D'Angelo imram kendi BLM Joy read
you create an endless supply of racism
even though there's no demand for it and
you can even find it in a child's
adorable painted face with more than $9
billion spent in 2022 alone on diversity
equity and inclusion it's become an
industry for race Hustlers incentivized
to find race and everything and it's all
connected by reducing human beings to
their immutable characteristics race
obsessed snail o oil snake oil salesmen
do us all agrave disservice while lining
their own Pockets but now that dead spin
is on the hook for doing exactly what
she does she may start seeing her
speaking gigs dwindle and if she
complains well it's mighty white of her
and by her rules that makes her a
racist let's welcome tonight's
guft from Macadamia to Democrats she's
an expert on nuts Fox News contributor
tulsy
[Applause]
gabber don't let his beard fool you he
wears it to get into R-rated movies
actor and standup comedian Tyler
Fischer she's got comedic flare and
removable hair best selling boxers
contributor cattive
[Applause]
true and in New York City tourists take
walking tours around his biceps New York
Times bestselling author comedian and
former
[Applause]
NWA you know tulsy I came up with a
phrase if I ever want to know the truth
it's called follow the money I just
coined it uh if you follow all you thank
you if all you have to do if you want to
find out why this stuff is effective
it's because people are paying for it
yeah and you don't have to try too hard
to to come up with it just use the
jargon do you think this will ever end
uh the the money driven mentality no
yeah uh it's it's so blatant to see how
people uh like her are being you know
obviously profiting heavily from this
ibram kendi profiting heavily from this
the thing that that should be uh
bothersome to everyone is how many of
these corporations are falling for it
and writing out these fat checks to be
fed this nonsense where they're saying
oh you know in order to be anti-racist
you actually have to be racist yeah uh
and that we should be judging people on
the the color of our skin as long as the
people being judged are white yeah and
um I think I think Jo and it's just
incredibly insulting when Joy Reed said
after Nikki Haley lost Iowa that it was
the fault of all of the white Christians
in Iowa uh and oh in New Hampshire and
in Nevada and likely soon in South
Carolina she's completely bypassing the
fact that hey we as voters aren't a
stupid as she thinks we are and that we
see Nikki Haley for who she really is uh
she is someone who is a neocon warmonger
who probably cuz she never served a day
in the military feels like hey I got to
look tough so let me go and start some
Wars regardless of the cost to human
life and and to our country um that's
that's who we see her as and and we're
thinking for
ourselves Tyler you're an AOW
racist yeah I heard him in the back me
too
shocking um what do you I said small
lives matter come on what about us that
is is so true they forget about us cuz
they don't see us they can't see us they
can't see it's not our fault okay
looking down is
[Laughter]
hard what do you make about this what of
the Dead spin lawsuit it's like a
perfect consequence you know it's like
this kid is going to basically bankrupt
that company that's what's going to end
this is lawsuits I'm actually personally
suing a acting manager who said they're
not hiring straight white men anymore I
recorded the phone call and I'm taking
them to the Supreme Court and uh that's
that's been Ono for two yeah yeah are
you serious yeah that's real it it it
doesn't get any press you know cuz as a
black woman I nobody cares about me
right but no I I mean first of all
what's gayer than a rainbow headdress
racist maybe but not homophobic at all
also the cine Chapel God is touching
fingers with a naked guy right call him
racist but he's not homophobic where's
that representation yeah maybe she was
is homophobic that's exactly right she
didn't like to see two men touching
fingers that's exactly right frankly
neither do I I mean no I'm kidding
cats how you doing over there great yeah
trying to figure out what to ask you but
I'm just take it from here yeah well
yeah yeah what do you think about
whatever I just said great great great
I'm so glad you asked um well she CU she
we're talking about race but she also
said patriarchy right she also said the
cine Chapel was basically sexist she saw
some sexism in this painting from the
1500s cuz it's just a bunch of dudes and
my thought was like wait till she hears
about the rest of the
1500s I Googled women's rights in the
1500s and Google was just like no
yeah no there are no hits yeah no
seriously I think you're owned by your
parents and you're owned by your husband
so I like she thought that she really
had a hot take there but I don't think
the take's really that hot that the
1500s were kind of sexist yeah you know
originally they were going to call it
the good old
days you still call it that yes yeah yes
fun times back in the 1500s Tyrus oh
yeah real blast for
me you not going to be on the show
tomorrow when we talk about Sunny hustin
I'm so pissed off oh man I don't care
wherever I am they weren't that tall
back then we were we just ate you fast I
we
just here's
the she's she's a brilliant racist mhm
because she knows to just say this they
create a monster that's not there they
can control it and bring it back and
corporate can still do dirty things and
have right people working overseas for
10 cents but they pay one person 12
Grand a year which I'm open to
negotiation and to come in and tell
every one what's wrong with them it's
like that stuff that you used to do for
money in in England where someone would
pay you to beat them up and tell them to
be better yes you know and that's what
this is It's she goes in there with
feelings and doesn't matter she's good
doesn't matter what's on the wall she'
be like the orange on Gutfeld
represents the oppressive burn of the
Flesh of the yellow man who has to put
up with being underpaid on the Shelf so
if everyone could please reach your
hands in your wallet tens and 20s please
pass them to me so I can fight this
horrible orange oppression it's not my
favorite color I like green I said I
like green cat was cool with green you
had to have orange and it was your white
privilege that allowed you to pick the
color orange when we clearly did not
want the color green see I can do that
job that's easy she they're full of they
say things that don't matter to anyone
they make all the money she knows
nothing about what she's talking about
the 16th chapel the 14th Chapel the 11th
Chapel she don't know she's got no clue
she just says things and people say huh
the nice thing is people are fighting
back yeah the only thing I disagree with
I hate that you have to mention that the
young boy just happened to be Native
American yeah he didn't have to be
Native American to wear a Chief's
headdress and paint his and cheer for
his team any child any fan in America
that wants to put on a headdress and
support the Chiefs you go right a damn
head you don't have to be connected to
although maybe change the name of cinee
Chapel to CIS normative Chapel hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else